ted joining us now with a look at our
forecast and boy today was just
beautiful it wasn't too breezy either
we've had the wind the last couple of
days and also the morning temperatures
were mild too right you get up you're
like no jack
there was no jacket no sweatshirt even
no sweatshirt this guy put shorts on
he told me that earlier
tmi i apologize no it's okay just go
ahead and fight that visual but guess
what though shorts weather for sure
these next couple days this weekend
shorts weather for sure next week
not so much and we'll show you why
coming up live look outside right now at
the las vegas strip this is alaska
corporate camera we did have some breezy
winds early early this morning and they
started to relax as we got through the
day reid picked up the biggest gusts at
28 along with north las vegas centenni
hills 23 spring valley 22 miles per hour
again not strong enough for wind
advisories to be issued here for the
lake it was locally stronger closer to
40 that wind advisory for the lake and
the colorado river was allowed to expire
at 6 p.m 68 right now centennials along
with sky canyon spring valley 73 69
north las vegas mid 70s for whitney
ranch green valley and same for sunrise
manor 72
mountain's edge and same for henderson
right now still very pleasant out there
pump at 70 64 currently for boulder city
69 sandy valley clear skies on the
doppler network no rain at all we
certainly need it now next week we'll
see a system dive down look at this from
the pacific northwest we're tracking
this and this could give us some
sprinkles around the region right now as
far as widespread showers not going to
happen not a lot of rain with this one
but we will look for the chance for
sprinkles and that could change as we
get closer to that event as this
forecast evolves and that system evolves
so we'll keep you posted on that right
now a very only slim chance for us to
get any precip but we'll take anything
again wind forecast for tomorrow a
little bit of a breeze tomorrow nothing
too bad again all across the valley
there
and we'll see saturday those winds look
at this a lot calmer that's your
saturday so you've got a weekend
recreation maybe you're going out for
valentine's day dinner should be nice
outdoors 49 overnight cool and mainly
clear 75 for tomorrow that way above
average we're not going to reach that
record at 79 tomorrow your eight day
forecast shows a fantastic weekend but
from monday valentine's day to the next
day look at that almost a 10 degree
temperature drop we'll have more on
those cooler temperatures next week
tonight's games at home though even
though it's cool you'll be at the
t-mobile arena maybe on wednesday and
friday for for the game good idea it's a
good plan for trying to segue over to
you
yeah